basically the two ways that you see loss
of of wealth of the middle class are
literally less ownership of assets and
in the UK that's primarily housing the
other thing is just much higher levels
of debt so I mean you really you know
people our age if you speak to people
our age you can see it these guys number
one much less likely to own property
than their parents were at the same age
number two if they do own property the
amount of debt they have compared to
what their parents had at the same age
is absolutely enormous that is the loss
of the wealth of the middle class and
the exact same thing has happened to
governments they're privatizing assets
they're losing assets they're going into
debt and the question you to ask
yourself is we can't all lose our assets
right they're not disappearing someone
has to own them and we can't all go into
debt debt is always to somebody so as
the middle class is accumulating these
massive mortgage debts and student debts
especially in the US and the government
is accumulating these massive government
debts someone is on the other side of
that